We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The thing about being wrong is that before you know you're wrong, it feels exactly like being right. If we knew that we were wrong, we wouldn't be wrong.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。关于犯错，有一点是：在你意识到自己犯错之前，那种感觉和正确一模一样。如果我们知道自己错了，我们就不会犯错了。
Nobody's committing intentionally to a false belief about the world. If they are, they're not wrong, they're deliberately lying. Even during the construction of the original Takoma Nero's bridge, which was to become the third longest suspension bridge in the world, it seemed like something was wrong. Well, at least in hindsight, it seems like it should have felt that way, but that's not how Bean Wrong works. If you grew up like I did watching the Warner Brothers cartoons. This is Catherine Schultz, author of Bean Wrong, adventures in the margin of error. The Sunday morning cartoon moment where the roadrunner is dashing off the cliff and the coyote is
没有人会故意去相信一个关于世界的错误信念。如果他们这样做了，那他们不是错了，而是在蓄意撒谎。即使在最初的塔科马海峡大桥建设期间，这座即将成为世界上第三长的悬索桥，似乎也出了什么问题。好吧，至少事后看来，似乎当时就应该有这种感觉，但“犯错”的运作方式并非如此。如果你像我一样是看着华纳兄弟的动画片长大的。这是凯瑟琳·舒尔茨，《犯错：误差边缘的冒险》一书的作者。周日早上的动画片片段里，走地鸡在悬崖边飞奔，而歪心狼在
following him and of course the roadrunner can fly and the coyote can't and there's this great moment where he's run off the cliff but he has not yet realized that you know he's there's no solid ground underneath him and the moment when we're wrong about something but before we've realized it is like that moment we think that our belief is rock solid we think we have you know all of the the fact in the world bolstering us we feel like our giant suspension bridge is not going to collapse we have all of the fact in the world bolstering us. We feel like our giant suspension bridge is not going to collapse. We have not yet looked down and realized that that's not the case. I know this sounds crazy, but even during its construction,
追赶他，当然走地鸡会飞，而歪心狼不会。有一个很棒的时刻，他跑出了悬崖，但还没有意识到他脚下已经没有坚实的地面了。当我们对某事犯错，但在意识到之前，就像那一刻一样。我们认为我们的信念坚如磐石，我们认为我们拥有世界上所有的事实来支撑我们，我们觉得我们巨大的悬索桥不会倒塌。我们还没有低头看，意识到事实并非如此。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但即使在施工期间，
the deck of the Tacoma Nero's bridge would go up and down by several feet with the slightest breeze. Construction workers on the span chewed on lemon wedges to stop motion sickness, but construction continued, because the bridge had been designed specifically to withstand winds up to 120 mph. So everyone thought everything would be fine. Well, almost everyone. The original Tacoma Nero's bridge designed by Clark Eldridge was pretty conventional for a suspension bridge, but it was later modified by Leon Moisef to be slimmer and more elegant. The most notable change was the 25-foot lattice of
塔科马海峡大桥的桥面也会随着微风上下起伏几英尺。桥上的建筑工人嚼着柠檬片来缓解晕动症，但施工仍在继续，因为这座桥的设计初衷就是为了抵御高达每小时120英里的风速。所以每个人都认为一切都会好起来的。好吧，几乎每个人。最初由克拉克·埃尔德里奇设计的塔科马海峡大桥对于悬索桥来说相当传统，但后来被莱昂·莫伊塞夫修改得更纤细、更优雅。最显著的变化是25英尺的晶格
stiffening trusses underneath the bridge on the original drawings were replaced with an 8-foot solid steel plate girder. The new solid girder along the side and moissive design made for a much lighter, slimmer and more flexible bridge. It also got the wind like a sail, but they didn't know that. Moissive design was also two-thirds the price of the original Eldridge design, and that fact ultimately won the day. Eldridge and other state engineers were said to have protested, but it didn't matter. The original Tacoma Nero's bridge opened to the public
桥下的加劲桁架在原始图纸上被8英尺的实心钢板梁所取代。侧面新的实心梁和莫伊塞夫的设计使桥梁变得更轻、更纤细、更灵活。它也像帆一样兜风，但他们当时并不知道。莫伊塞夫的设计价格也只有埃尔德里奇原始设计的三分之二，这一事实最终胜出。据说埃尔德里奇和其他州工程师曾表示抗议，但这无济于事。最初的塔科马海峡大桥于
on July 1st, 1940. From the day it opened, it was prone to having these oscillations, these longitudinal waves of the bridge deck. That's our master of disaster, John Marr, and I write on various murders and disasters in other sundry topics. He used to publish a scene called Murder It Can Be Fun about these sundry topics. He wrote about the Tacoma Narras Bridge years ago. The workers on the bridge had nicknaded Galloping Gourdy, and that quickly kind of became the bridge's unofficial name. Even light winds caused the roadway to ripple with longitude and a wave, some five feet high.
1940年7月1日向公众开放。从开放的第一天起，它就容易出现这些振荡，即桥面的纵波。那是我们的灾难大师约翰·马尔，我撰写关于各种谋杀和灾难以及其他杂项主题的文章。他过去曾出版过一本名为《谋杀：这可能很有趣》的杂志，专门讨论这些杂项主题。他多年前写过关于塔科马海峡大桥的文章。桥上的工人们给它起了个绰号叫“跳跃的格蒂”，这很快就成了这座桥的非正式名称。即使是微风也会导致路面产生纵向波纹，有些高达五英尺。
Sato Washington was concerned about this, but not like intensely, so they were like looking at various things to reduce the motion. They tried some tight-down cables and installing a damper and various other things, none of which had worked. But again, the roadbed seemed like you could handle the waves, just fine. They're very confident in the structural integrity of the bridge. The bridge was as solid as the air underneath Wiley Coyote's feet.
华盛顿州对此感到担忧，但并不是特别强烈，所以他们一直在寻找各种方法来减少这种运动。他们尝试了一些系紧电缆、安装阻尼器和其他各种方法，但都没有奏效。但同样，路面看起来似乎可以很好地处理这些波浪。他们对桥梁的结构完整性非常有信心。这座桥就像歪心狼脚下的空气一样坚固。
When you watch film of the waves traveling down the bridge, it is stunning. And the fact the bridge stayed open at all really illustrates how local governments have changed since 1940. That thing would never stay open today. If you were sitting in a car on the bridge when the waves were going, the cars in front of you would bob up and then disappear completely from view.
当你观看波浪在桥上移动的影片时，它是令人震惊的。事实上，这座桥一直保持开放，这确实说明了自1940年以来地方政府发生了怎样的变化。那东西在今天绝对不会保持开放。如果你坐在桥上的车里，当波浪起伏时，你前面的车会上下颠簸，然后完全从视野中消失。
Almost like it's real ride, people would actually try specifically for the feeling of riding on this bouncing bridge. The ride ended just four months later. Gone about fatal day, and the wind begins to speak with a roar that no man can fail to hear. It was clear early on the morning of November 7th that the Gail Force winds were having a greater effect on the bridge than ever before. Previously, these sort of waves on the bridge had been like a fairly transitory. It did bounce up for a couple of minutes,
几乎就像真正的游乐设施一样，人们甚至专门为了在摇晃的桥上行驶的感觉而来。这段旅程在四个月后结束了。在那个致命的日子里，风开始咆哮，任何人都无法忽视。11月7日清晨，很明显，大风对桥梁的影响比以往任何时候都大。以前，桥上的这种波浪相当短暂。它确实会上下跳动几分钟，
but this was just going on and on, so they thought this could be a problematical, although they had seen actually deeper waves on the bridge. But then the movement changed. Things just got worse. The bridge began to twist violently along the center of the line. And that became like extremely violent. One end in the bridge deck was up at a 45-degree angle.
但这只是持续不断，所以他们认为这可能是一个问题，尽管他们实际上在桥上见过更深的波浪。但随后运动发生了变化。情况变得更糟了。桥梁开始沿着中心线剧烈扭曲。这变得极其剧烈。桥面的一端处于45度角。
In a 40-mile-an-hour day, the feather span leaves like a ribbon in a swing with the two wooden-believe potholes as the bridge gyrates like a nightmare high above the river. Twisting, turning, curling. By this time, everyone had gotten off. The blunt solid edge of the bridge disrupted the flow of the strong wind, causing one part to twist up while the other section twisted down, and it continued this torsional back and forth for over an hour, so there was plenty of time for spectators to come watch, including the bridge's original designer, Clark Eldridge. A local camera store owner named Barney Elliott arrived in the scene and took the now famous
在每小时40英里的风速下，桥面像秋千上的丝带一样摆动，随着桥梁在河面上方像噩梦般旋转，两个木制的坑洞摇晃着。扭曲、转动、卷曲。到这时，所有人都已经撤离了。桥梁平坦坚固的边缘扰乱了强风的流动，导致一部分向上扭曲，而另一部分向下扭曲，这种扭转往复持续了一个多小时，所以有足够的时间让观众来观看，包括桥梁的原始设计师克拉克·埃尔德里奇。一位名叫巴尼·埃利奥特的当地相机店老板到达现场，拍摄了现在著名的
color film of the bridges for relentless gyrations. No structure of steel and concrete can stand such a flame, steel girders buckle and giant table snap like Tunie Friends. There it goes! Engineers are divided as to the cause of the disaster. Some claim it was the use of solid girders, others dipper, but whatever the reason to coma will rebuild. This time a bridge that will not provide a super-thrail in the news.
桥梁无情旋转的彩色胶片。没有钢筋混凝土结构能承受这样的折磨，钢梁弯曲，巨大的电缆像细线一样断裂。它倒了！工程师们对灾难的原因存在分歧。一些人声称是使用了实心梁，另一些人则有不同看法，但无论原因如何，塔科马都将重建。这一次，一座不会在新闻中提供超级惊悚片的桥梁。
Before the collapse, bridge aerodynamics and structural failure due to torsion had scarcely been considered, or maybe those lessons had been lost in the rapid evolution of more and more slender and longer bridges. But the failure caused the study of bridge aerodynamics to take off, and any bridges that were on the drawing board in 1940 were redesigned with more conservative, deep open-trust deck structures. The lead designer, Leon Moistiff, and his solid steel eye beams received most of the blame for the disaster. He never designed another bridge again. Doing no small part of the fact that he died three years later.
在倒塌之前，桥梁空气动力学和因扭转导致的结构失效几乎没有被考虑过，或者这些教训可能在越来越纤细和更长桥梁的快速演变中被遗忘了。但这次失败促使桥梁空气动力学的研究起飞，任何在1940年处于绘图板上的桥梁都被重新设计，采用了更保守、更深的开放式桁架桥面结构。首席设计师莱昂·莫伊塞夫和他的实心钢工字梁受到了灾难的大部分指责。他再也没有设计过另一座桥梁。这在很大程度上是因为他在三年后去世了。
No one was killed on the bridge. A few people were very lucky to get away with their lives because I just imagine you're on this bridge and is twisting it at a 45 degree angle and trying to walk off in a fairly stiff wind. The only casualty was a dog. A local newspaper man named Leonard Cotesworth drove his car just past the east tower when the twisting started. You got bouncing so hard he couldn't control his car anymore. The tilting bridge threw his car into the side- side curb. And he had his daughter's dog, a coccrospanol named Tubby with him. Coachworth gets out of his wrecked vehicle
没有人死在桥上。有几个人非常幸运地逃脱了，因为我只是想象你在这座桥上，它以45度角扭曲，并试图在相当大的风中走出去。唯一的伤亡是一只狗。一位名叫伦纳德·科茨沃斯的当地报社记者在扭曲开始时开车刚过东塔。他颠簸得太厉害，无法再控制他的车了。倾斜的桥梁将他的车甩向了侧面的路缘。他带着他女儿的狗，一只名叫塔比的可卡犬。科茨沃斯从他损毁的车辆中出来，
and gets thrown face down on the curb. The dog's completely freaked out, he couldn't get the dog out. He hears the concrete cracking beneath him. And he barely makes it to safety. An engineering professor studying the bridge named Farcarson ventured out to get Tubby right when the bridge was about to fall into the sound.
然后脸朝下摔在路缘上。狗完全吓坏了，他无法把狗弄出来。他听到脚下的混凝土在开裂。他勉强逃到了安全地带。一位研究这座桥的工程学教授法卡森冒险出去救塔比，就在桥即将坠入海峡的时候。
But when he reached into the car, Tubby bit him. The dog was just too freaked out to leave the vehicle. There's an amazing film of Farcars and stumbling back as best he could, sticking to that middle yellow line, as the bridge rocked wildly along its center axis. So, Tubby was the only casualty, and you know, guy, I said, I don't have to tell my daughter this. Coachworth was quoted immediately after the collapse, saying, with real tragedy, disaster, and blasted dreams all around me.
但当他伸手进车里时，塔比咬了他。那只狗太害怕了，不肯离开车辆。有一段令人惊叹的影片显示法卡森尽可能地踉跄着退回，紧贴着中间的黄线，而桥梁沿着中心轴剧烈摇晃。所以，塔比是唯一的伤亡者，你知道，伙计，我说，我不必告诉我女儿这件事。科茨沃斯在倒塌后立即被引用说，周围都是真正的悲剧、灾难和破碎的梦想。
I believe that right at this minute, what appalls me most is that within a few hours I must tell my daughter that her dog is dead when I might have saved him? This next bit is a completely unrelated adendum that will serve as a valuable life lesson to any 99% invisible fan. Here's John Marrigan. Several years ago, I went to the Portland Zines symposium to do a seminar on research based zines. to the Portland Zines symposium to do a seminar on research-based scenes. Research-based scenes like research-based blogs or podcasts have always been a bit in the minority. Anyway, and was held in this building
我相信就在这一刻，最让我震惊的是，几个小时内我必须告诉我的女儿她的狗死了，而我本可以救它的？接下来的部分是一个完全不相关的附录，将作为任何《99%隐形》粉丝的宝贵人生教训。这是约翰·马里根。几年前，我去了波特兰杂志研讨会，举办了一个关于研究型杂志的研讨会。研究型杂志就像研究型博客或播客一样，一直处于少数。总之，它是在那栋楼里举行的，
called the Michael Smith Memorial Student Union Building on the Portland State University campus. Very first thing I did, I got into the class and said, okay, this panel is being held in the Michael Smith Memorial Student Union Building. Does anyone who Michael Smith was? No one did. Michael Smith was the captain of the Portland State University College Bowl team. The College Bowl was a televised trivia competition matching teams from various
叫做波特兰州立大学校园内的迈克尔·史密斯纪念学生会大楼。我做的第一件事，我走进教室说，好吧，这个小组讨论是在迈克尔·史密斯纪念学生会大楼举行的。有人知道迈克尔·史密斯是谁吗？没人知道。迈克尔·史密斯是波特兰州立大学大学碗队的队长。大学碗是一项电视转播的知识竞赛，匹配来自全国各地不同
universities throughout the country. And he led Portland State University to the championship, which is just incredible accomplishments. They're beating out schools like Harvard and Yale. And this is Portland State. This is a state school. I mean, this is not the type of school that you expect to win something like this. I'm sure the Ivy League people were horribly embarrassed and it was quite a big deal at the time. He also was suffering from cystic fibrosis and he would die three years after this. So everyone agreed this was a good story. You ask me how do you find out about this? There's a plaque in front of the building. My slogan is always read the plaque. That's great.
大学的队伍。他带领波特兰州立大学获得了冠军，这简直是不可思议的成就。他们击败了像哈佛和耶鲁这样的学校。这是波特兰州立大学。这是一所州立学校。我的意思是，这不是你期望赢得这种比赛的那种学校。我相信常春藤盟校的人当时感到非常尴尬，这在当时是一件大事。他还患有囊性纤维化，三年后他就去世了。所以大家都同意这是一个好故事。你问我你是怎么发现这个的？大楼前有一块牌匾。我的口号总是阅读牌匾。那太棒了。
99% invisible was produced this week by, Roman Mars, and special thanks to John Marre of Murder Can Be Fun, and Alan Bellows of the website Damn Interesting. We are a project of KLW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% Invisible is provided in part by Tiny Letter. Email for people with something to say. My boy, Maslow, always has something to say. What do you have to say, Maslow?
《99%隐形》本周由罗曼·马尔斯制作，特别感谢《谋杀：这可能很有趣》的约翰·马尔和网站“Damn Interesting”的艾伦·贝洛斯。我们是旧金山当地公共广播电台KLW 91.7和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。《99%隐形》的支持部分由Tiny Letter提供。为有话要说的人提供的电子邮件。我的男孩，马斯洛，总是有话要说。你想说什么，马斯洛？
What we basically talk about is world-bots and iron and tips and stuff. Robots and iron man suits. I would subscribe to that newsletter. It's free, easy, minimal, powerful, the simplest way to write an email newsletter. Online at tinyletter.com. This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public find out more at prx.org. And while I'm talking about PRX, I have to tell you about another podcast they produce
我们基本上谈论的是机器人、钢铁侠和技巧之类的东西。机器人和钢铁侠套装。我会订阅那个通讯。它免费、简单、极简、强大，是撰写电子邮件通讯的最简单方式。在线访问tinyletter.com。该节目由公共广播交换中心PRX分发，使公共广播更加公开，欲了解更多信息，请访问prx.org。当我在谈论PRX时，我必须告诉你他们制作的另一个播客
called How Sound by the genius Rob Rosenthal. If you're a person who loves radio and is also the type of person who listens to the director's commentary on DVDs, then How Sound is the show for you. Check it out at HowSound.org. My man Sam Greenspan took off for a while to launch the Ted Radio Hour at NPR, but he'll be back. You'll be back, Green's Band. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I would like it if you would like us. A tweet at Roman Mars,
叫做《How Sound》，由天才罗伯·罗森塔尔制作。如果你是一个热爱广播的人，也是那种会听DVD导演评论的人，那么《How Sound》就是适合你的节目。请在HowSound.org查看。我的伙计萨姆·格林斯潘离开了一段时间去NPR推出了《Ted Radio Hour》，但他会回来的。你会回来的，格林斯潘。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。如果你能点赞我们，我会很高兴。在推特上@罗曼·马尔斯，
but you can always catch up with us online at 99%invisible.org. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你总是可以在99percentinvisible.org在线赶上我们。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。